في زمن تصريحات من وظائف التكنولوجيا يبقى
هناك اناس في امان من هؤلاء هم الحرفيون
والعمال المهره بريطانيا مثلا التي تشهد
ازمه اقتصاديه كشفت ارقام من كونفدراليه
العمل والتوظيف ان عجله الانتاج مهدده
بسبب الشهور ملايين الوظائف من العمال في
قطاعات مختلفه واستدعوات لتسهيل هجره اليد
العامله الى بريطانيا الدنمارك ايضا اعلنت
عن قائمه وظائف جديده لشغل الاف الوظائف
وفتحت باب تاشيرات والهجره لاحرفين بينما
في المانيا كشفت احد اصحاب المهن الحره ان
نقص العمال المهارات السبب في مشكلات لدى
العديد من من يعملون لحسابهم الخاص
اسمع في الاونه الاخيره كبر الشركات
التكنولوجيه والعالميه تسرح الموظفين هل
بالفعل يمكن القول ان المهن الحرفيه باتت
البديل الافضل اليوم في زمن الازمات
الاقتصاديه والماليه صحيح سهام خصوصا الان
يعني مثل ما قلتي مش بس شركات التكنولوجيا
يعني على سبيل المثال امازون تسريحه 18000
اليوم البنوك ايضا بلشت بالتسريح بسبب
بوادر الازمه الماليه يمكن
الاخرى اعلن عن تسريحه اكثر من ثلاثه
اهداف
فبالفعل هناك همم تسريحات كبيره في القطاع
المهن الاخرى الان بالنسبه للمهن الحرفيه
هي اشياء دائما نحتاجها يعني دائما انت
تحتاجين سباك دائما تحتاجين كهربجي
فيعتمد ايضا باي مكان بالفعل خصوصا في
الاردن انا اهلي عايشين في الاردن كان
يجينا سبعك بالاول قبل سنتين كان ياخذ على
الانسبكشن او الزياره 10 دنانير ما يعادل
تقريبا 50 درهم او 50 ريال اليوم ياخذ دبل
بالضبط بعد سنتين 20 وحتى تشوفين شايل
شنطه مثل دكتور ومرتب ولابسه كذا مش
الفكره اللي فينا وطبعا في اوروبا هذا
الشيء بعد اكثر يعني هناك مش واحد صلح لي
شيء خلص صار سباك او صار كهربجي لا هناك
في شهادات ومعتمده ما يقدر يشتغل شغلات
تدريب ودراسه ومعاهد متخصصه ونقابات تخصصه
تحميهم وفي بنت معين للاجور خصوصا في
اوروبا مثل ما قلنا يمكن البارح كنا
بنتكلم في نيويورك او اوروبا الدنيا
كلها
بنايات قديمه تحتاج الى الكثير من الصيانه
ازدهرت ايضا من الاشياء اللي اثرت على
اعمالهم وعلامات خولهم ورواتبهم انه زادت
الطلب عليهم خصوصا في فتره كرونه فما بعد
لانه احجم الكثير منهم عن العوده الى سوق
العمل لما كانوا ياخذون المعونات سواء
باوروبا او همم معونات الحكوميه او با
فيقول لك خلاص انا اقعد في البيت اشتغل
يعني في بريطانيا ذكرتوها بالتقرير وصل
الامر الى الاستعانه بالسجناء
كقصابين في في الملاحم الدجاج والخرفان
والى اخره فكان الامر بهذا السوء انه كان
هناك نقص لدى زادت اجورهم بعد اكثر من
السنوات اللي قبل